just looking at where blue origin is  looking at where spacex is today  and maybe looking out 10 20 years out  from now  are you impressed of what's happening we  just saw william shatner go up to space  yeah i was i was just watching his video  the this morning before i came here yeah  are you impressed of where things stand  today yeah i mean  i mean spacex  in particular is has  done things that are just unbelievable  um  and um  yeah i don't think anyone was  anticipating  um 20 years ago let's say when this all  started just the uh the speed with which  they'd be able to um rack up these  incredible  achievements  if you've kind of uh  even seen a little bit of how the  sausage is made and and so the the  difficulty of of doing any kind of space  travel  what they've achieved is  is just  is unbelievable  you